[Musique]
avoir des enfants bon plan mais c'est
une ourse je me fais pas trop je me
mette le crac
ce soir je veux être un pont du lourd ce
qu'il a raison mais tu as plutôt l'air
d'un nounours désordonnée chaque fin
juin le vote bon le seul homme propose
au peuple au
bon soir alors on s'amuse
j'ai envie de rire ce soir même à sa
cravate
et la mise à l'heure tu fais comme le
roi dagobert
assieds toi là
et voilà une belle couronne à présent tu
ressens mais je n'ai pas de culot ça
fait rien tu fais comme si tu en avais
le pourquoi taco bell a mis sa culotte à
l'envers
legrand cède élevé ni honorons votre
majesté et mac hulot dit je veux lui dit
lourd moi je veux la remettre à
l'endroit
comme l a fait à cros labre mieux faire
le grand stade éloi le duo mauroy votre
majesté pour un ca blessés c'est vrai
lui dit laurent
donne un sabre de bois mais pour weight
bien comme elle elle n'est qu'un loyer
eau ni vers le grand stade d'el ouali au
moment votre majesté mafara gelés c'est
vrai lui dit laurent tu peux souffler
sur tes droits mais pour moi dagobert
chasser dans la plaine donnèrent le
grand stade éloi le dit comment votre
repas juste bien essoufflé
se voit lui dit le roi alain couret
après moi le bon roi dagobert
goulaine embarqué sur la mer legrand
chuté loi le dit oh mon roi votre
majesté sépharade noyer c'est vrai lui
dit normand
pourra crier le roi
et à présent le roi dagobert
ordonne à ses charmes en vassaux d'alu
ou totaux de tout tout de suite majesté
on y va mais sur leroy beaulieu
[Musique]
fans et n'honorera gaubert
menu nicholas carr bien petite soeur
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez tous chanté cette
jolie chanson avec nicolas et
pimprenelle
alors tu arrives nounours le roi
dagobert rorive accroc en route cyr
bonne nuit des enfants
allez sagement vous couchez donné de
gros baiser à vos parents est fait pour
[Musique]
oh
où